[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruse and i'm i anna-wade and
this is your news for Monday November
13th first up we wanted to talk about
some posters and first looks like we got
from some movies first and foremost the
Black Panther character posters they're
super cool they look really awesome and
get some really detailed shots of like
some of the makeup and costumes that we
could see that we haven't really gotten
but that's about it
that's all he kind of got was just some
cool character line ups but you know me
and my kit my my costumes I like to see
those little baby details so for any
cosplayers that I've been wondering what
to do this is perfect for you definitely
one of my favorite things though has
been seeing on Twitter some people
photoshopping things into like Panthers
hands specifically the one that's been
roaming around of him holding a kitten
yeah it's adorable does made me giggle
another processor that we got this week
was for Deadpool - yeah and it was a
holiday poster for Thanksgiving it's
mimicking the famous Norman Rockwell
painting but in it is the Deadpool
family and the Deadpool is there serving
a turkey and everyone sitting around it
looked really cool looks interesting I
just the marketing campaign on this is
gonna be amazing
what how amazing the first Deadpool
without a campaign oh yeah this has to
step up its game and so far I think it's
delivered because in addition to that
poster we also got a fake mock-up of a
Good Housekeeping mm-hmm featuring
Deadpool in the holiday special and they
had some really funny you know little
funny article titles my favorite one was
like turkey cooking tips how to give
your family the bird for those some kind
of funny and mature joke but I mean it's
a dead bull
I just can't wait to see it yeah
absolutely we have plenty of time for
more marketing oh so we're looking
forward to more of that you give it to
us yeah we want it we also got a first
look at Doctor Who's Jodie Whittaker
as the thirteenth doctor and her new
costumes that's right her haha I'm very
excited for it's got cool rainbow
sweater
it's got those sweet suspenders I'm
guessing it replacing the classic
bowties yeah cool it's great but don't
worry she's still got a sweet jacket so
if any was worried about the jacket
sweet jacket yeah um it's very
reminiscent to me a Victor Garber's look
in Godspell
if anyone sobs that movie gets got the
suspenders in the sweater great great
nothing here obviously but I love it
hey in those trousers man those are some
sweet trousers I'm just saying that you
can rock a great pair of suspenders
I can't this week we got a whole bunch
of trailers as well one of the first
ones that I am personally very excited
about is we got a final trailer for
shape of water which is the air Mel del
Toro's new monster movie and I just love
his films and I cannot wait to see this
and this final trailer has kept the hype
going and is really delivered um in case
you don't know what it's about or
haven't seen any of the trailers it's
about a fish-type monster who has been
apprehended by the US government and
there are these two women who clean his
tank and are the janitors in the area
and one of them falls in love or starts
to kind of get a connection with the
monster and attempts to save him by
removing him from the facility because
it seems like the US government wants to
cut him open and take them apart and see
how he works and then we also have the
Soviets thrown in there are trying to
kill it as well so it seems like it's
going to be a really heartfelt action
thriller with even some espionage thrown
in there and I just cannot wait I love
guillermo del toro and that's gonna be
out on December 1st so I don't even have
to wait that much longer yeah it looks
beautiful so we'll definitely be
checking that out another trailer we got
this week was the first trailer for the
new movie
game night which is starring Jason
Bateman Rachel McAdams alongside awful
host of hilarious actors and it's sort
of a statement gone wrong if you will a
group of adults are getting bored with a
classic statement and less things up a
little bit so that's a recipe for
disaster because someone actually gets
kidnapped and it's a murder mystery
night gone rogue and it looks hilarious
and I will definitely be checking this
out it looks very funny as they venture
through it and try to figure out like
what is this real is this fake what's
what's happening it seems like a really
interesting take on the concept Oh for
you tonight yeah absolutely another
trailer that dropped this week was for
the Netflix original series dark which
is a German original series so the
trailer is actually subtitled and you
should apps and check it out so it looks
booby is all get-out oh my goodness
looks so scary and I'm very excited for
it because those Germans know how to
tell some scary children's stories it
very much looks like it's gearing off of
the its and stranger things crowd
because it's the leads of children who
go missing and it's yeah there's kind of
like a lot of mystery to it it was very
scary it's not super clear what's going
on with the kidnapper wearing what he
does with these children wear and win
right because it seems like there's
definitely time-travel involved because
there's some weird machine things but no
idea really interesting yeah it comes
like over their eyes and then there's a
whole bunch of maybe he's here I'm
washing them to be like the next
kidnapper because like it's set over
time I don't know I have no idea there's
no really yeah you just got the trailer
but don't worry we don't have to wait
very long because that also comes out on
December 1st lots of things to watch for
Christmas break the Halloween into the
rest of the holidays that's what we need
some big news that we got this week from
Disney is that they're launching a new
Star Wars trilogy uh yeah it's crazy
right dozen is going to be writing
producing directing I don't know he's
attached to the project maybe doing all
of these he's doing the first one we
know I thought he was doing the whole
tree no for the first we're assuming the
wrath
but he's writing off a trilogy yeah and
I mean I think this is good news there's
so much material out there of the
extended universe is so large in star
wars that there are a ton of stories
that they can tell especially since they
said that this is not going to be
related to the Skywalker saga yeah which
is a complete departure from what the
rest of the movies have been right so
I'm sure they're trying to create a
whole nother set of sequels prequels
whatever that can continue on and
there's material to do it and the world
one didn't really do a sequel no right
and then they're also doing a Star Wars
live-action television series that are
going to be on the new Disney streaming
service so it is just everything's
coming up Star Wars lore everywhere and
I'm okay with it as long as we're going
to keep it good
well it's sound could be asking at least
the last Jedi is good because if Rian
Johnson is getting the whole trilogy
after it like okay great yeah
so we've at least got last Jedi so good
news good news good news on all fronts
right but with the Disney streaming
service they also said that they're
doing some other live-action shows so
there'll be a new Marvel show right as
well on the streaming service which I'm
assuming means that as soon as the
contracts are up with defenders punisher
daredevil it's gone with netflix yeah
we're having a new Marvel show
live-action Star Wars a Monsters Inc TV
show high school musical television show
you have the Hobbit for all age ranges
yeah yeah get that content sure
so since Netflix is losing some
superheroes they are gaining some more
Netflix just picked up the Umbrella
Academy for its own series and Ellen
Page is signed as the lead for now so
Ellen Page violin player but super
powers absolutely sign me up
that sounds amazing that's all the news
we have right now so we can wait for
more casting and
other announcements for that in the
future no tune in Netflix also announced
this week that they are branching out
into comics yes
liking physical comics that you can go
to your comic store and buy not just
television shows so the new comic is
going to be called magic order and it's
written by Mark Millar who they've
actually bought out his whole extended
universe and self-published works so
we'll definitely see a lot of his
material out there on Netflix but I
think it's a really interesting idea
that they're branching out into physical
comics I mean if you have this Brandon
you have a good comic writer why not
absolutely why not so I'll probably be
checking that out and it's but it's not
gonna come out until spring of 2018 so
we still got a little while away for ya
work on that make it good yeah I think
that's gonna be it from us here guys so
if there's something that you want to
see in the new Star Wars trilogy let us
know in the comments down below what do
you think they will cover who's the
character in the extended universe they
would love to see being covered we would
love to hear from you otherwise you can
get at us on social media how they where
can people find you um you can find me
on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash other routes and you could always
find me at Facebook at I gotta wait and
everywhere else is awesome Ayanna that's
gonna be it from us here guys anything
else let us know in the comments down
below otherwise we will catch you next
week in the meantime beam us up
[Applause]
you